welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Sarah Schneiderman an assistant
professor of anthropology at Yale
University professor Schneiderman is a
socio-cultural anthropologist working in
the Himalayan regions of Nepal India and
China especially the Tibetan Autonomous
Region her research addresses the
relationships between political
discourse ritual practice cultural
performance and cross-border migration
in producing contemporary ethnic
identities since 2009 she has been
involved in a project entitled
inequality and affirmative action in
South Asia current experiences and
future agendas in India and Nepal today
we talk with her about that project and
her research on inequality and
affirmative action
welcome professor Schneiderman thank you
let's begin with an overview of the
project tell us a little bit about it
okay well it came together as a
partnership project between several
junior scholars we were all based in the
UK at the time because I completed my
postdoc at Cambridge University just
before coming to Yale so several of us
based in the UK and then several
scholars in India and Nepal and all of
us were interested in the policies of
affirmative action but more importantly
what its results look like on the ground
and lived reality many of us are
anthropologists there are six of us
involved in the project and one is a
historian one is a political scientist
and one focuses on education but all of
us wanted to look in a more fine-grained
manner at how people on the ground in
various communities understood the
policies that were being formulated and
then reacted to them in terms of their
own cultural practice in everyday life
so we got together and put in an
application to the British Academy to
have a three year set of research
research initiatives in which we would
look at both India and Nepal
comparatively speaking
to understand how the history of what
are often called reservations in India
that's but a system that's been in place
since the 1950s and it's one of the
oldest and most robust systems of
affirmative action anywhere in the world
what we wanted to understand was the
implications of that history for current
debates in Nepal which is currently in a
moment of state restructuring there's
been a ten-year long conflict which
officially ended in 2006 between the
state and Maoist insurgents and in the
wake of that post-conflict settlement a
new Constituent Assembly was elected and
one of the major agendas of that new
governing body in Nepal has been to
develop the country's first-ever system
of affirmative action because Nepal is
located adjacent to India and has a
great deal of cross-border historical
connections and also contemporary flows
of people and ideas and so forth it
seemed like a natural thing to do to
bring the conversations which have been
ongoing in India for a long time about
these issues into the discursive
environment in Nepal of course some of
that is already happening at the policy
level but what we wanted to do was to
bring a rigorous scholarly perspective
to bear on some of these two policy
debates and particularly an ethnographic
perspective so one like I said at the
beginning that would look really in
detail at how people were experiencing
policy and how they were transforming
their lives in relation to it and then
how in effect they might also request
the state to transfer form the policies
for them alright before we go any
further let's define what you are
calling affirmative action mm-hmm okay
well this is a term which can often be
very controversial and it's taken to
mean different things in different parts
of the world in India it's largely been
discussed as equivalent with positive
discrimination so basically any measure
which all other things being equal gives
special benefits to people of certain
recognized groups because they're
perceived to have a past of
discrimination and not equal access to
often government resources jobs
education and so forth
so affirmative action actually refers to
a broad range of possible initiatives
some of which can be positive
discrimination as I just just described
there's also a concept of positive
action which
is more prevalently used in the UK which
does not actually include specific
benefits but it engenders it aims to
make available information to people
from a wider range of different groups
so there are many different forms of
these affirmative action measures I know
the project is wrapping up in 2012
they're having their final conference in
July are there any particular goals that
you would like to have seen the project
reach at that point well our major goal
has been to create a body of literature
on this material that's what been one
goal another goal has been to actually
bring this scholarly material into play
and the policy arena and so we see some
of that happening we currently have
three different publications in process
resulting from the work in the project
and I should say what some of that work
has comprised has been research projects
mostly carried out by graduate students
in India and Nepal funded through this
project and supervised by myself and the
other members of the partnership in the
UK India and Nepal and so they've
conducted case studies in different
parts of both countries looking at these
micro level dynamics so some of that
work will be published in an edited
volume in Nepal some of it will be
published in a special issue of an
anthropology journal which myself and my
co-editor and project organiser
Albus Shah are editing she's at
Goldsmiths College in London and then in
the summer conference in Kathmandu we'll
be bringing together scholars from all
over the world who have worked on these
dynamics both to talk with each other to
see what's unique about the Nepal
scenario which can yield insights for
scholarship more broadly defined but
also what kinds of insights those
scholars can contribute to the dynamics
in Nepal and that conference will also
include meetings between the scholars
and Nepali Constituent Assembly members
and other policymakers involved in the
top level discussions there have you
done any comparative analyses between
Nepal for instance and perhaps the
United States or any other countries
this is something which is of great
interest to me and is a direction that
my own work might go in I'm actually
teaching a class
here at Yale in the spring which is
titled affirmative action in South Asia
and the US and so through that class
I'll be beginning to look at some of
that literature of course the
comparative project is really important
and there have been scholars who have
looked at particularly the example of
India in relation to what it might offer
to the US but most of that analysis has
come from quantitative perspective so
from sociology political science
economics looking at the numbers does
affirmative action action actually
increase people's socio-economic
standing but what I'm more interested in
looking at is how it actually affects
people's sense of identity and their
cultural practices and so that's a
perspective that we've been able to
develop in the South Asian context which
I also think it would be really useful
to apply here in the US okay I know you
believe that there should be affirmative
action especially in Nepal can you kind
of extrapolate on that a little bit why
you feel that way again this is a very
controversial issue and I want to make
clear that I'm not in favor of
affirmative action measures that are
applied in a sort of haphazard manner
rather I think that careful research is
necessary to understand what the
underlying social and cultural dynamics
are and that's of course what we're
trying to do through this project and
then applying that knowledge part of the
issue in both Nepal in India has to do
with histories of classification how
people are actually classified so that
they fall into categories that could be
beneficiaries of affirmative action in
India some of the categories are called
scheduled tribes and as our st so people
who come from ethnic communities or a
caste I mean I know that the caste
system is still in place in India so
that I would imagine is as part of those
tribal groups you know so there are two
separate groups scheduled tribes are one
legally recognized set of groups and
there's many many groups within that
large scale designation and then
scheduled castes are the other group and
those are communities who historically
would have been at the lower rungs of
the Hindu caste system so otherwise
known as Untouchables or adul it's then
there's another set of groups which the
Indian state
more recently recognized called other
backwards classes and that is the
official legal term so what happens
through all of these processes of state
recognition is that people actually have
to prove their eligibility for belonging
to one of these groups and that leads to
all kinds of cultural politics that can
be very difficult and divisive now in
Nepal the same sorts of groups exist in
the sense that there was a caste system
which is officially illegal but still
continues in practice in the sense that
people do discriminate against others on
the basis of caste and there are also
many ethnic minorities who do not fall
within that caste system and because of
this stratification which was also
legally recognized by the state in legal
codes going back even to the 1850s
basically people have not had equal
access to education and resources over
time and in Nepal it's only been after
1990 that it's actually been legal to
talk about ethnic difference before 1990
when the country returned to democracy
you couldn't even use an ethnic name or
an ethnic language in any kind of public
domain and due to that history of
discrimination and marginalization
people feel very strongly that there
need to be some sort of corrective
measures to that just to give you a few
statistics for instance in Nepal in the
civil service so this is 2010 data the
Brahmin group which is the top level of
the caste system is about 12% of the
population but they have over 70% of the
top level civil service jobs by contrast
the ethnic minorities are about 30% of
the population but they have only around
1% of the civil service jobs so the
inequalities are very vast and in order
to bring that sort of inequality into
some sort of balance within a relatively
short time frame during the process of
state restructuring that's going on now
in Nepal many people feel that it is
necessary to have these kinds of
measures and I support that really on
the basis of my ethnographic work with
people from marginalized communities who
express those sorts of desires to me it
seems like it would be a very
complicated policy to put forth I mean
so what is the current situation now in
Nepal for instance
yes it is very complicated and of course
that's a term that scholars like to use
a lot and so the question is how we can
distill some of that complication into
something that's actually practicable at
a policy level in Nepal there has been a
Constituent Assembly so basically a
governing body which is at once meant to
govern but also to draft a new
constitution that has been in place
since 2008 after elections were called
for the first time in over 10 years and
they were supposed to draft a
constitution within two years but they
missed that deadline then it was three
years they missed that deadline and now
they're continuing to work on that and
one of the main divisive issues is this
question of affirmative action how to
actually set it up in a way that occurs
people who were discriminated against in
the past a fair chance without creating
new forms of discrimination against
members of the previously dominant group
so this is a subject a very active
debate and it's in tandem with the
discussion about state restructuring so
Nepal was a unitary state in the sense
that it had no States or federal
structure like we have here in the u.s.
it was just one homogeneous polity and
now the idea is to break it down into
fourteen different provinces each of
which might in fact be governed by an
ethnic my Nick group that is dominant in
that area but as you can imagine this is
also very controversial and so the
question is how can equality actually be
assured in a way that doesn't actually
fragment the state and also makes people
feel like they're all getting equal
access to the limited resources the
state has to offer I mean it's something
that you can probably debate and talk
about forever but it gets to a point
where you have to stop and say okay
right here's what we're going to do so
that you have not reached that point yet
and Nepal no I mean of course many
people have their own ideas about what
should happen but it still has not been
actually formulated in in any kind of
legal manner those Constituent Assembly
debates are ongoing and as a point of
comparison in India the Constituent
Assembly debates had a similar form but
were held between 1948 and 1950 and
India's affirmative action system
emerges out of those debates so what
happened in India 50 years ago is
happening in Nepal now and that's why
the comparison between the two countries
and taking lessons learn from India's
fifty years also about the negative
sides of affirmative action and what
might Nepal might do to avoid some of
the problems that India has encountered
that's a very valuable what exercise
what are some of the challenges that
India has encountered um well one of the
one that I look at most carefully in my
own ethnographic work is it relates back
to this issue of classification that I
mentioned earlier so basically what are
the criteria out there for a group to be
recognized as a scheduled tribe well in
India the list dates to 1965 and it
includes evidence of being primitive and
these are the Indian government's terms
not mine geographical isolation
backwards Ness their own traditional
culture and some sort of oral tradition
so they're very normative terms that
basically say people should have this
kind of cultural practice if they are to
be recognized as tribal and so what that
has compelled as a whole set of cultural
performances by which people try to
match that criteria by outperforming
each other as evermore tribal so people
who may on a normal day wear a shirt and
pants and work in an office in front of
a computer when it comes time to
actually put on a performance for
members of the state who may be part of
the Commission which would verify their
community as a tribal group they'll put
on what they perceived to be tribal
costumes often creating things which
never previously existed and so there's
a kind of fabrication of culture that
goes on which in itself is not
necessarily negative but it begs the
question of what actually are the
criteria for recognition and why do
people actually have to manipulate their
daily reality in order to gain benefits
which really should be tagged to
economic inequality not the performance
of certain cultural traits and so this
is a problem that's now widely
recognized in India but the question is
how do you transform those legal codes
at this particular moment whereas Nepal
has the opportunity not to reify culture
as a criteria but instead to find ways
of evaluating economic inequality and
the ways
it's linked to cast an ethnicity and a
much more nuanced manner and there are
various groups that are actively trying
to come up with those definitional
rubrics and what do you think the future
holds I mean how far down the line how
many years perhaps do you think it will
take before something is instituted in
terms of affirmative action particularly
in Nepal
well we'll have to see they now actually
have a deadline for the Constitution
hold on it's September August at the end
of November but it remains to be seen
whether that will actually come to pass
or not the very sticky issue in Nepal
again is this issue of federal
restructuring on the basis of ethnicity
so should there be new provinces or
states which are delineated along ethnic
residence patterns and as you can
imagine that's a very controversial
issue so will that happen or not we
still don't know my hope is that they
will find a way to institute affirmative
action at a central state level so that
these powers are not devolved to newly
formed States but rather are
administered from whatever remains of
the central state so that such policies
can be formulated in a way that are
equitable for people living all across
the country regardless of where they are
actually having new states with new
administrative structures to set up
responsible for developing affirmative
action policy at the same time seems
like a great challenge to me yes I agree
well thank you so much for being here
with us today and sharing some of your
work thank you very much for more
information about Professor Schneiderman
and her research please visit our
website at Yale edu backslash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale